hi I'm Nicolas be with Matt Welch this
is asked a libertarian 2012 we're
celebrating the paperback release of the
Declaration of Independence at the end
of the month check it out online or in
your local bookstore our next question
comes from ken kelly via email with ron
paul's retirement who do you see will
pick up the mantle of the libertarian
movement I think that's no one will on
some level Ron Paul I think has been the
biggest gateway drug for a lot of people
into libertarianism over the last five
years through his two presidential runs
he's drawn in a lot of anti-war people
who've been exposed to libertarianism
people chant ed end the fed at college
campuses in the thousands it's a pretty
remarkable run he has a certain anti
charismatic charisma an adherence to
principle which is a totally unusual
unheard of in politician I don't think
we're going to have a character like
that again I think what we'll have
instead are people who use many of the
same principles there or the same kind
of foundations as he has and mediate
them more in the political world so
someone like Justin Amash i think is an
obvious person and i'm hoping that he
wins his reelection in in michigan in
Congress I think Rand Paul in many ways
is a very effective libertarian senator
in Congress and then hopefully we've
just seated both the polity but also
people outside of politics with people
who are trying to advance the cause of
freedom one way or the other I don't
think you necessarily need a single
shining light to guide the path for
everybody libertarianism is an
essentially American kind of impulse
Jeffersonian it's right there kind of in
our history I think Americans are
positively inclined towards it and there
are thousands of next ron paul's but not
any of them will be probably as
individually influential as here you
know like mad i can't thank ron paul
enough for articulating principles in
politics and also showing that that's
immensely powerful and popular this is a
guy who is a you know relatively
anonymous congressman who's really
shifted the way that the Republican
Party and the nation is talking about
politics and policy more power to and
there will
be many people beyond Ron Paul let will
pick up the mantle and some will go
further than others one of the things
that's great is that over the next few
years pragmatically governments are
going to have to become more libertarian
they're going to have to reduce their
size scope and spending because they
just don't have the money we're starting
to see that at the state and local level
it's creeping up to the federal and even
the international level so I think Ron
Paul has made clear why we need to do
that and how we might start doing that
and that's going to be a hell of a
legacy for more on ron paul c senior
editor ryan Doherty's book ron paul's
revolution and for more ask a
libertarian to keep watching this space